well it's a nice to say I'm now joined
by no Gallagher no lovely to see you how
are you very good thank you now there
are rumors that you're going to be doing
a duet with Coldplay this evening is it
true no no I'm doing it with Holly Moss
is it gonna be Coldplay me and Ollie are
going to bust up a medley of Sex Pistols
classics in the style of Riverdance
and lots to look forward to obviously
your duets with holy Moses coming up
really excited commonly known as their
seminal Brits mom wouldn't think to let
some always the key moments of the Leah
walls I mean which one stand out to you
in the last few years I mean what's the
last few years I've got to say I haven't
seen it for a while I'm all about the
90s that's me anything about the
nineties of sport only one now they're
trying to put the music back into the
bristle was for a while it was arguably
a big party lots of booze not much music
now they want to put the onus back on
the music do you think that's a good
thing move with the times only I guess
this award ceremony as far as I'm aware
I've been for a few years and it's
already sings very very slick now to me
it used to be a bit ramshackle and you
know like you say a bit of Otoniel but
it's all very very slick now I mean but
then it's all of modern age I guess to
me all these young kids want some slick
slick modern award ceremonies do miss
the 90s what do you think was better
everything
the music industry was bad nobody had
mobile phones nobody on iPad
nobody had cameras in phones that's the
most annoying thing that the modern age
of bras is the camera in the phone I
miss all I do i mister all I miss my
stamina you Lisa Lisa's yeah yeah yeah I
also miss my waistline you know my
ill-fitting clothing you back console on
your own at the moment how is it
performing on your own without boys like
that don't say it's any better or worse
it's just different you know it's a
different a different thing you know I'm
playing different songs to seemingly
different audience the younger audience
but I thought - you closed through to
touch it you know I mean it's I people
have asked for what the gigs have been
like and they're literally passed me by
in 10 minutes ago I've got sing remember
the words you play the guitar you know
do all that kind of things so I don't I
don't really know what I'll probably
make a DVD of it and watch it back at
Christmas I think it was all are you
enjoying it though you still get a buzz
that I don't think anybody who doesn't
enjoy doing it you know I mean everybody
will enjoy it to a certain degree I mean
I love it I love writing songs and
that's the bit I like the most is the
creating something from nothing
and I like all I got the same when I
stopped enjoying I won't do it anymore
I'm gonna do some house but whittling
and assessing and in terms of British
stars today are you a fan of a Down
Coldplay which is the one for clarity
yeah I do like Coldplay then you got to
say that cuz you're performing with them
tonight who sort of that yeah
what Chris is a friend of mine but I do
genuinely like Coldplay Adele like I
have a pit an opinion it-it's not my
kind of music tonight I mean it's I
don't we don't own their records but I
believe she's a great singer and she is
big in America
and she swears a lot but she's not so as
much as I do I'm really old in this in
for the viewers of Sky News really I'm
swearing like a super insider Adele she
seems so cracked America when so many
British artists have been able is it
turn crack in America it's a British
term that nobody knows quite what it
means a me worried
I don't know what you have to do to
crack America's there's some kind of
criteria you've got to sign up to
because we've all cracked him Erica in
some ways they're not I mean yeah well I
guess she's selling a lot of records out
yeah thank you so much for your time
well gotta go performing this evening
maybe with all you MERS who knows